à l'image du nutrisse corps qui mesure
la qualité nutritionnelle d'un produit
alimentaire l'écho score luis en
mesurant l'impact environnemental de la
même façon les produits sont classés de
a à e selon un code couleur à
représentant un faible impact du produit
par exemple des fruits et légumes
origine france auront tendance à avoir
un faible impact environnemental avec un
code couleur vert tandis que la viande
importée aura tendance à avoir un
mauvais échos score
l'objectif de cet indicateur rendre
l'empreinte écologique que génèrent les
produits transparents mais aussi
sensibiliser sur les modes de
consommation
elle nous avons interrogé les yvelinois
pour savoir si un écho score pourrait
changer leur manière de consommer
regardez j'ai lu d'ailleurs un article
il ya quelques mois sur l'apparition de
ce système là
oui c'est un grand problème c'est
certain et commencent à filtrer un petit
peu en france auprès de certains
produits
à ce moment là oui je privilégie la
qualité à tallec au score à dix ans oui
je pense que ça peut changer ma manière
de consommer s'il est mis sur les
produits que comme pour le nid crise
corps je le regarderai donc peut-être ça
changera certaines choses je vais je
vais voir suivant ce qui sera mis sur
les produits
c'est important pour l'environnement
pour le futur de la planète pour pour
les enfants qui arrivent
l'écho score est basé sur une
méthodologie il s'appuie sur les données
des analyses de cycle de vie des
produits qui a été réalisé par l' agence
de l'environnement et de la maîtrise
d'énergie
elle calcule un score sur son à partir
de plusieurs critères comme par exemple
la recyclabilité des emballages ou
encore l'origine à des produits
plusieurs acteurs de l'alimentation ont
d'ores et déjà lancé cette
fonctionnalité depuis le début de
l'année c'est le cas par exemple de
scanner open foot fact ou encore you cas